sa teinte
cesse crème skin care ce crime a le
droit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si la loi
ça
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
halloween c'est la seule fête un ou
quand tu es chez toi il à n'importe qui
qui tapent à la porte qui est tellement
une film d'horreur sur halloween
n'importe qui tapent à la porte à une
race track it au monde mon frère non
mais c'est vrai
[Musique]
andy
andy sétois
les enfants
[Rires]
j'avais le chien kobe
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que ces bonbons
[Rires]
louise mon frère
il ya des enfants qui viennent pour
tanguay pour vienne tutoient leur donner
des mouvements frère c'est pour ça que
moi mes enfants ils ordonnent de
l'oseille direct ils disent on veut pas
ils ont peur mon fichier khamassi fait
peur à tout le monde dans l'immeuble
mais c'est vrai qu'halloween ca devient
une fête grâce à des roms valérie bénaïm
fait très peur comme ça ah ouais non
mais franchement j'appréciais nom venant
passionnés personnes enlevées moi c'est
clair
mais je veux non mais c'est vrai sans
rigoler c'est un truc de fou en vendée
c'est la trouille halloween away à josé
serra et vous savez que
[Rires]
franchement
beinheim bon gros saisissez vous avez
déjà vu un fantôme avec une voix
tunisienne
sur ma vie elle est la tape à la porte
on y donne des boulettes à sa nation
à beinheim servat pas ça parce qu'à moi
allez les chéris 2e puck toc toc c'est
parti
alors
non déjà le toc toc toc est tellement
lourd
et
tous
[Applaudissements]
un
trottoir
[Applaudissements]
les athées vitryat déguisé en dise à
isabelle oui c'est halloween
donc pensé faire peur dans ce
déguisement c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
c'est un truc de fou sahili mais c'est
rien c'est oui ailleurs j'ai vu le film
d'horreur mais bon je grogne à oui c'est
un mec s'habillant grunge fait peur à
tout le monde
sur la planète il sera marqué dans les
films bourget raconterait l'histoire
avant je regardais une oreille film
d'horreur sur ma vie franchement des
fois il sort une maison ah oui
maintenant tu vois que la maison
alleyras radio et la meuf elle est toute
seule elle va absolument rentrer dans la
maison voir ce qui se passait très rock
ce que je m'en fous drôle que dans la
maison si loin de la maison surexcités
pas le glas du livre la bombe à qui elle
non elle veut rentrer dans la maison
sera d'ivoire pourquoi il a deja ça car
autres perdants de la maison je fais
zigouiller et la nuit et après il ya
toujours des gens ils viennent toujours
sans la seule dans la maison mais un
autre qui vient tout seul et voilà ils
voient ça
et on fait un bilan indique que des
morts tenez bon mais retrait dans une
maison il mourir sortie mais à la fin
avec que des bords dans la maison et
j'ai rien compris au film the grudge
je crois début je croyais tech crunch je
crois que c'est un truc sur le chocolat
sur ma vie ne le voyez pas ce film j'ai
vu sur my canal alors il ya des trucs
magnifique sur la canal notamment validé
jeudi renault s'est dit tiens je vais
faire un petit film d'horreur mais comme
ça bah ouais pour proposer de changer
lisez les coen quoi bein l'indicé crime
enquête criminelle mercredi film
d'horreur et puis voilà et puis jeudi
pour vraiment avoir très peur je regarde
le 6 à 7
généralement avec montiel tu prend dans
la gueule
allez c'est parti pour
aller pour château toc toc toc
le clown est espelette
nationale qu'il a compris ce que c'est
le squelette qui à l'afp qui a vu les
fuseaux les les faits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vient de montrer le
benjamin castaldi il fait perdre un
bâtiment on peut être ridicule
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas est vous avez vous avez
j'avais vraiment le sens du rythme il
voit rien il va toujours rien tapé la
balle jaune
comme celle de l'après dit voilà quelque
chose perd jamais franchement non
oh lalalalalalalalala scénario c'est pas
possible mais castaldi ce pas possible
un casque castaldi mais ressaisissez
vous met les tripes et
qui à côté de vous ouais c'est assez
verdez non
c'est parti françois toc toc
déjà la personne a raconté comme ça ça
non elle reflète le toc toc toc
iphone
moi je vais parler je suis dit que ça
lui dire
il faut dire toc toc toc
je viens de voir la personne c'était
comme en branle à rabat en data grid
c'était quand même l'ancien porte-parole
des républicains
ce qu'elle est avec nous ce soir c'est
l'ancien porte-parole des républicains
là ça rend la politique fun exactement
où je l adore mais franchement c'est
vrai mais c'est sympa que face à un oui
je dois aller je roule à doha elle est
très belle en plus en dracula comme ça
ça lui va très bien pourquoi en dracula
aller alesi total pack qui m
dracula bon dracula cuir vivaki
dracula là
[Applaudissements]
et en ville vous mettrez à côté de
l'autre krainer là bas
j'espère connaître perdu damiani
bertrand qui met les deux je vais pas
vous lâcher dans le mois comme ça
surtout vous ne bougez vous lâche comme
ça si on fait un peu d'argent week end
le problème c'est qu'on a toujours très
peur qui dérape ouais il est toujours
même en la limitant à l'ailé n'a pas de
limites réservé avec samantha ah oui bah
allez c'est bon merci tu nous fais chier
montrez-leur tout cas et je vous jure
bernard que je trouve très beau comme ça
et elle est très fin ces 20 euros
bravo
c'est gentil merci ça m'amuse beaucoup
c'est sympa oui ça pouvait pas nous
faire un discours politique comme ça et
votez pour moi
c'est vous présenter un jour à une
élection
peut-être je vais voir je vais réfléchir
d'accord ça va dépendre quand vous me
virerais je retourne en politique
[Rires]
jean
fouquet ben je vais me dépêcher
dont vous serez toujours avec moi c'est
quoi la vocation de l empire c'est quoi
la vocation des vampires c'est sucer le
sang pourquoi
pas la proche
d'être est agité par la roja toc toc toc
comment sais tu sais que c'est bizarre
on sait qu'ils
côtoient que ce qui m'étonne le qi est
le clone si je n'existais pas
[Applaudissements]
ce
[Musique]
comme encore reconnaissait pas leur
souffrance à petit clown chez ge qui
n'existait pas c'est l'étude mirai
shida turner tu te mets là bas
merci à tina merci
ya beaucoup à faire et ça va mais cette
année on n'a rien d'un tourneur et de
2,2 de verdasco à côté de rancune de la
mouvance est pas
bon tu l'as a fait
passer ce pacte du sang
d'accord merci des mousses et à côté de
ça me fait beaucoup de peine non
vraiment pas si j'avais la jambe comme
toi je vous dise importante nous
fait plus de bananes ou encore en tout
cas en tout cas je reste comestibles
jaber qui m'envoient baba j'adore
montiel gens n'en démord pas
merci madame
tarif de groupe attendait
bernard montiel ya ya ah ouais y'a
clément guérin qui nous regarde mon ami
clément que l'ado qui me rappelle toi
cloront sa vie que bernard était son
gros coup de coeur chroniqueurs et
qu'elle était fan absolu de lui mais là
ce soir je peux pas
évoquer sa mémoire elle voit pas mais on
sens mais rien sur moi non en fait elle
ne vous voit pas ne vois pas les gens
beaux
non je rigole pas c'est comme dans le
sixième sens
elle vous adore elle parle même plus de
vous parce qu'elle vous entre temps elle
vous adore voulait venir manger à la
maison ben ne prenez pas au moins
par contre manger proprement la branche
connais mes isabelle je vous invite à la
maison j'adorerais une boulette qui veut
venir à bannu allez isabelle et moi
allez prochain de toc toc à uniterre
[Applaudissements]
l'ascenseur thierry se resserre encore
bon j'avais 20 ans vainqueur c'est le
temps
[Applaudissements]
m
face à des bisontins on dirait edith
piaf écoutez je suis une sorcière qui
fait pas très très peur d'accord nous
allons vous allez bien mais fiona
tréviers vous cyril très bien ma chérie
samassa laurent de malraux qui travaille
demain écoutez oui si travail demain il
accorda il faudra regarder le rouquin
oui y ont été intéressés parce que c'est
l'assistante de long rouquet aussi fiona
et seraient ravis de me voir habillée
comme ça je crois oui non mais c'est pas
mal donc ça va bouger tient la campagne
paraît oui mais comment vous savez ça
vous savez tout une fête c'est vous qui
m'avez dit non je voulais pas dit non
maintenant vous le saviez je le savais
pas ce que vous avez demandé de venir
hier et vous avez immonde innove
finalement là la campagne et j'ai dit si
je prends un train j'arrive tout de
suite et finalement ils ont trouvé mais
en ce moment un train pour revenir et
oui vous avez bien fait de rester à la
campagne émission était pour rien
non pas du tout c'est bien écoutez
c'était très bien je n'avais pas peur à
la campagne la campagne à une ambiance
toujours un peu de films d'horreur enfin
la campagne série le ch était à quand
donc on en moins dit c'est pas non
plus d'amis là bas raconte c'est vrai
oui tous les gitans de congeler en
brasse vendredi notamment mon frère au
clan bradfort voilà non mais c'est vrai
donc sans peine vous fait flipper vous
la campagne dans une maison de campagne
frère ben oui tu as toujours une petite
race track pontons des bruits dans une
maison de campagne très resserrée mais
le contenu avec est contée avec genre
des gens ils sont persuadés j'aurais
font surtout mis tout est normal
maintenant toute la nuit tentant d
bricoman
genre tu crois qu'un cas me fedida
faisons là je le sois la nuit nantes
inquiète c'est rien ça c'est neuf c'est
une bonnette des pyrénées
tac tac tac aller
c'est qui grichka
bogdanoff kabok d'acquis
d'habitude
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on tire pas un bail et si les
tuteurs rendez vous à la clinique lundi
matin
on dirait fin cassen dit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose
qui se casse la gueule
à
l'été comme délégué syndical ça peut
être deux plantes que j'attends
[Rires]
toc toc toc qui est de
[Applaudissements]
70 home
temps d'attenté parce que sa photo comme
bizarre
aux photos marie si tu savais
[Applaudissements]
le
cet automne je te le dis j'ai rarement
vu un fantôme avec une baguette magique
on boit pas
fantômes des prêts pour dubaï
bon ça va
pas bien aller mais toi là et tient
france à la non mais non je suis normal
j'ai rêvé tout non
jardins jardin non j'ai pas de jardin
non non je n'ai pas de petit
pied-à-terre
je commence à en avoir assez mais de
leur mouvement votre caf a les seins
alors franchement qui reste qui mais en
plus il y rit il a pris dans la gueule
vous avez été dur hier il a mangé été
dur je vais vous dire si on peut pas
parler un ami bon à rien c'est un ami je
dis tout je suis dit ouh là c'est pas si
on peut pas parler un ami c'est on peut
pas hurler à la lune on m'aide à écouter
je ne conçois pas amis alors fait ça
capte pas vous prendre une citrouille
dans la gueule
ça peut tomber ça peut tomber de partout
l'évangile ou d'amour
et la souris
chauve-souris talent
[Applaudissements]